- Luc Picard, vous incarnez
le tueur à gages Galald Gallant
dans "Confessions".
- Mmh, mmh.
- C'est tout un rr r r r r r r s
parce que Gérald Gallant,
il bégaie, il ufuffre aussi
beaucoup, or, comment vous avez
approché ce personnage-là
qui est
LUC PICARD,
acteur et réalisateur
- Oui, c'est quand mêmepopopopo,
mettons. J'avais des heures
et des heures d'inrrrrogatoire
de Gallant et puis je regardais
ça à temps perdu, je le faisais,
je le pratiquaisàààààààààààààààr
- Dans la vie!?
- Oui, oui. J'essayais ça
avec mon gars. Il est
un bon oeil. Puis je disais :
ça sonne-tu naturel? Pendant
à peu près sept ou huit mois,
j'étais un peu là-dedans.
Je pratiquais tout seul danseied
parce que quand tu t'arrêtes
à la lumière rougeleles autres
te regardent comme si t'étais
fou, t'sais.
♪ ♪ ♪
joué les criminels dans "Moïse",
l'histoire de Roch Thériault,
dans "Le Collectionneur" aussi,
les criminels comme ça, est-ce
qu'en carrière vous avez déjà
reçu, c'est une question que
je lance comme ça, des menaces
ils ont des cercles rapprochés,
ces gens-là?
(rire)
- Oui. Bah, écoute, c'est
la première fois que
quelqu'un vraiment... il y avait
Moïse, mais Moïse était
c'est vrai que quand tu tournes
un film comme celui-là,  y y a
toujours cette espèce de petite
inquiétude. Mais j'essaie
de pas trop... penser à ç
- Ma question n'était pas
si bonne que ça.
- Non.
votre carrière : Pierre Bernard
au théâtre?
- Oui.
- Pierre Falardeau aussi?
- Oui.omomomomomomomomomomomomo-
là, ces deux artistes vous ont
montré du métier qui vs s suit
encore aujourd'hui?
de choses, mais je dirais
peut-être que si j'ai  t trouver
un mot, c'est la sincérité,
et chez Pierre et chez Pierre,
les deux. Et l'idée e e e e e e,
le devoir de rêver, en fait.
Le... ça me touche comme
question. Hum...
Excusez...
- Coupé! En fait, c'est ça,
c'était ma paine question :
Pierre Falardeau nous a quitté
il y a plus de 10 ans, il me
manque, quququququququququququqe
côté artiste. Qu'on l'aime ou
qun n ne l'aime pas, Pierre
Falardeau, il était sincère, on
dirait que ça nous manque, ça,
- Euh... oui, ça nous manque
que c'est sûr que la rectitude
politique fait que... Rectitude,
c'est-à-dire, bon, ça dit déjà
une chose, personne peut
être contre la vertu, sauf qu'i
exprimer qui ne sont pas
toujours si vertueuses que ça,
puis si tu fais juste
juste mentir. Fait que tu n'es
pas plus avancé. Donc, des fois,
il faut pouvoir se laisser
Puis, il faut avoir le droit
de se tromper, tu sais, parce
tromper, tu ne feras jamais
grand-chose. Puis la beauté de
l'être humain, c'est d'avoir nos
failles aussi, c'est pas juste
quand on est adéquat ou coeseses
humains que j'aime, c'est leurs
failles que j'aime, t'sais.
- Vous avefififififififififififs
belle aventure de toute votre
vie. Arsrs comment, justement,
cette aventure-là a changé
votre carrière et votre façon de
jo
Parce qu'encore une fois,
vous êtes très émotif l
qui est comédien.
(rire)
- Oui. Euh, oui. Bien, Henri,
ça a changé ma vie parce que...
c'est parce qu'un ieieieieieiei,
tu passes à côté. Je veux dire,
tu... C'est fa p pour ça,
changer ta vie.  q q q q q q q .
Fait que je ne serais jamais
devenu réalisateur.
Je ne veux pas lui mettre ça
sur les épaules, mais je suis
d'Henri. "L'audition",
c'est parti d'une lettre que
qu'oui, c'est ça. Fait qu'Henri,
c'est une révolution, comme
je pense que les enfants doivent
toujours être des révoluonons
pour les gens qui qui les font.
- Là, je tente ma chance, est-ce
que vousraravaillez sur un film
sur Guy Lafleur?
- Oui, moi je vois très bien
voununununununununununununununu:
Guy Lafleur plus vieux.
- - Mmh, mmh.
- Je suis-tu loin de la vérité,
là?
- Oui, parce qu'on n'en est pas
là du tout. On en est vraiment
à essayer de trouver le...
On n'est pas au casting,
j'ai l'intuition que l'histoire
de Guy se rendra pas jusqu'à
cet âge, mon âge à moi.
Alors je pense que je suis trop
vieux pour... je suis trop vie
- On peut tout faire
en post-prod...
(rires)es limites,
quand même. Fait que, non,
je ne suis p r rendu là dans
les réflexions. Je suis vraiment
à l'écriture, donc.
cet été dans "Confessions",
mais aussi dans "Arsenault et
Fils", je veux vraiment le dire
parce que vous êtes aussi
extraordinaire là-dedans.
- Merci infiniment, merci.
- Sacrement, il est revenu!
Oh qu'il est beau!
(rir